اعلن عسكريون في الجابون انهاء النظام
القائم ووضع الرئيس علي بونجو قيد الاقامه
الجبريه بعيده اعلان فوزه بولايه رئاسيه
ثالثه كما اعلن تشكيل ما سموه لجنه
للمرحله الانتقاليه واعاده المؤسسات
وتوقيف ابن الرئيس ومستشاره وعدد من
مساعديه واعضاء حكومته من جانبه دعا
الرئيس المنقلب عليه اصدقائه للتحرك ضد
الانقلاب بحسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الخلفيات التي قادت
الى وقوع الانقلاب في الجامبو وما فرص
نجاحه في ضوء اعلان منفذه تشكيل ما سموه
مجلسا للمرحله الانتقاليه واعاده المؤسسات
مدى وجاهه الربط بين انقلاب الجابون
وسلسله الانقلابات التي سبقته في غرب
افريقيا خلال الفتره الماضيه واخرها
انقلاب النيجر وما التاثيرات التي يمكن ان
يحدثها انقلاب الجابون على مسار الاوضاع
في غرب افريقيا وعلى مصير الانقلابات
السابقه وعلى احتمال وقوع المزيد منها في
الفتره المقبله
اذا في بيان البثه والتلفزيون الرسمي في
الجابون ليلى ثلاثاء الاربعاء اعلن عدد من
الضباط الغاء النظام القائم ووضع الرئيس
علي بونجو قيد الاقامه الجبريه واعتقال
ابنه وعدد من مساعديه الى جانب الغاء
نتائج الانتخابات العامه الاخيره التي
وصفوها بانها تفتقر الى المصداقيه
نحن قوات الدفاع والامن المجتمعه ضمن لجنه
المرحله الانتقاليه واعاده بناء المؤسسات
قررنا باسم الشعب الجابوني الدفاع عن
السلام من خلال انهاء نظام القائم بهذا
الهدف قررنا الغاء الانتخابات العامه
ونتائجها المبتوره واغلاق الحدود حتى
اشعار اخر وحل جميع المؤسسات الدستوريه
الرئيس المعزول علي بونجو طلب في اول ظهور
له منذ الاطاحه به من سماهم اصدقائه
والعالم كله برفع اصواتهم في وجه من
اعتقلوه في اشاره الى قاده الانقلاب الذين
اعلنوا لاحقا قائد الحرس الجمهوري الجنرال
بريس اوليجي نجيمه قائدا للمرحله
الانتقاليه
انا رئيس الجابون اوجه رساله الى كل
الاصدقاء في العالم وادعوهم الى رفع الصوت
عاليا ضد من اعتقلوني واعتقلوا عائلتي ابن
معتقل في مكان ما ولا اعرف شيئا عن زوجتي
انا معتقل في بيتي ولا اعرفه ماذا يحدث
ادعوكم ان تحدثوا ضجيجا وان ترفعوا
اصواتكم اتوسل اليكم
[موسيقى]
لمناقشتي هذا الموضوع تنضم الينا من باريس
الدكتوره ليزلي فارين مديره معهد دراسات
العلاقات الدوليه والاستراتيجيه في باريس
من الكويت معنا ادريس ايه الاكاديمي
النيجيري والخبير بشؤون الافريقيه ومن
جنيف ضيفنا هو الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه جونيف مرحبا بكم
جميعا سنبدا معك سيد ادريس ايه ونريد ان
نفهم اسباب ودوافع هذا الانقلاب في
الغابون
2008 او 2009 حين وافته المنيه فقاموا
بالتنصيب ابنه بدل له كانه في اماره او
مملكه تاخذ سؤال وبانجو اضافه الى انه
2018 عيدا كانت هنالك مظاهرات
عارمه ضد علي بنجو نفسه اعصابه جلطه قلبيه
فغادر البلاد اللهم انه غادر البلاد في
هذه الوضعيه الخاصه ايضا قاموا بانتخابه
مره اخرى ودفعه في تقديمه البلاد
والانتخابات الراهنه في 2013 قبله قام
بتعديل في الدستور البلاد اضافه الى انه
قام
تقييد مما يتعلق بالحريات وخاصه
العذاب المعارضه
الانتخابات الراهنه شهدت ايضا شيئا اخر
وهو انه منع دخول المقاربين اقليميين
والدوليين كما قتل الانترنت كل ما يشيء ان
سيكون هنالك مزاوره وتزويرا ومحاوله
المرور بالقوه حتى اذا خسر الانتخابات
وهذا الذي ذكره البير البير
الزعيم التحالف المعارضه وقال ان
الانتخابات مبينه انها كانت مزوره من رجل
لا يستطيع ان يمشي ولا يستطيع حتى ان كمل
ايبار صحيحه مفيده في هذه الاجواء كانت
هنالك اللامبالاه من المجتمع الدوله
المجتمع
مجموعه السماك التي تعرف مجموعه من الدول
سيدي ادريس اذا افهم منك ان الاسباب
والدوافع لما جرى في الكابويا فقط داخليه
لا لا جزء منها داخليه لكن اعتقد ان الجزء
الاكبر والاهم داخليه باعتبار ان هنالك
شعب مستاء من عائله كانت تحكم البلاد في
دوله تعتبر الجزء الخارجي المتعلق بالامور
الخارجيه
اما فيما يتعلق بالامور الخارجيه فنستطيع
ان نشرح ذلك في
الجزء الاكليمي وكذلك
السياق الاقليمي الذي كانت تعرفه افريقيا
الفرانكفورنيا التي كانت تعرف الدومين
والانقلابات والتي تحاول ان تخرج من ابات
فرنسا والنفوذ فرنسا والدول التي او
الرؤساء والشخصيات التي تعتبر حليفه اوثر
حليفه لفرنسا وعلى راسهم عائله بونجو
وخاصه التي عرفت عائلته بدعم ليس فقط
معنويا لكن بدعم ماديا سياسيين وفرنسيين
من اليمين واليسار والوسط فجميع هذه
الامور ادت الى الدبات الصغار وكذلك عناصر
من المعارضه دفع البلاد الى تحقيق هذا
الانقلاب كنوع من موجه اقليميه فرنسا دانت
هذا الانقلاب ولكن ما حقيقه الموقف
الفرنسي وكيف تنظر فرنسا الى ما حدث اليوم
في الغابون
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه ان فرنسا قد دانت هذا الانقلاب
وقد طلبت امرا مهما بالنسبه الي مرتبطا
بنتائج الانتخابات بالنسبه الي طبعا نحن
نشهد سلسله من الانقلابات وهناك صعوبه
دائما في تحديد الامور في بداياتها ولكن
في النهايه نتمكن من فهم المشهد بالنسبه
الي هذا انتهاز للفرصه من قبل العسكريين
الذين استفادوا من الانقلابات التي جرت في
بلدان اخرى نحن نتحدث عن انقلاب داخل
العائله نتحدث عن
قبيله وعشيره بونجو اذا انجيما ايضا عمل
مع دونغو منذ العام 2009 وبالتالي نتحدث
عن امور داخليه في القصر الرئاسي
الليله يمكنني ان اقول اننا نتحدث عن ثوره
داخليه على المستوى على مستوى القصر
الرئاسي اكثر منها انقلابا عسكريا في
النهايه نتيجه الانتخابات
اعلن عنها في خلال ساعات الليل وطبعا اتت
باعاده انتخاب علي بانجو ولكن اذا ما اراد
العسكريون ان يشن هذا الانقلاب لاحلال
الديمقراطيه كان يتعين عليهم ان يعطوا
النتيجه الحقيقيه للانتخابات وحقيقه ما
حصل وبالتالي
الخاسر الاكبر هو المعارض
وعدد من المعارضين والاحزاب الداعمه لسيده
يعني افهم منك ان
هذا هذه النظره الفرنسيه الى ما حدث انه
انقلاب داخل العائله بحلول نيجيما الان
على راس الدوله كما قال
الانقيابيون قبل قليل وبالتالي هل يفسر
هذا الموقف الفرنسي الذي كان ملطفا انجاز
التعبير بالمقارنه مع الموقف الذي سمعناه
عندما حدث مثلا انقلاب النيجر
ولكن فرنسا هي في وضع
صعب ومزعج بالنسبه اليها لان كل البلدان
في افريقيا
تثور بين مزدوجين والتي كان فيها تاثير
فرنسي ولكن هناك خصوصيه لكل انقلاب وهذه
خصوصيه الانقلاب انما تتحدث فرنسا عن
اهميه نتيجه الانتخابات بالتالي هذا الامر
يسلط الضوء على ضروره اعطاء او نشر
النتائج الحقيقيه بالانتخابات التي جرت
بالنسبه الى مانيويل ماكرون طبعا هو يعاني
من صعوباتا بالنسبه الى هذا الامر امره
معقد في المرحله الراهنه بالنسبه الى
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه وبعد هذا الامر يجب ان
نرى هل نحن نتحدث عن ثوره داخليه في
الاسره او نتحدث عن انقلاب الاحلال
الديمقراطيه دكتور حسني عبيدي
نقترب منك اكثر من السياق كما تراه القوى
الاوروبيه سياق الذي اتى فيه هذا الانقلاب
وسياقنا ينتج عن تراكمات عديده داخل
السلطه في الدوله يعني منذ
منذ اصابه الرئيس علي بونجو كانت هناك
نصائح موجهه اليه بان يترك السلطه وانا
اعتقد المدور تلك الفطره واصبح الرئيس لا
يتدخل او الى يتحكم في العديد من الامور
توقيف نجل الرئيس هو دليل على ان السلطه
لا تريد في النهايه ان ابنه يسبح وربما
الرئيس المقبل حتى في حاله تحويل السلطه
من العسكريين الى المدنيين بهذه التراكمات
نتيجه الحكم السيء
والممارسات للرئيس بانجو ثم كذلك للتحكم
العديد من المصالح العديد من اصحاب
المصالح داخل القصر الرئاسي
حتى يعني الممثل العسكريه جزء من هؤلاء
يجب ان ننسى بان الحرس
الجمهوري الذي قام بالعمليه هو نفسه الذي
في نهايه سعد الرئيس بانجو عندما استطاع
الرئيس السابق للاتحاد الافريقي كانت لدي
نتائج ايجابيه وتم في النهايه تنحيته
نهائيا من السياق السياسي داخل البلد
السياق الاوروبي بالضبط يعني باي عين تنظر
اوروبا الى ما يحدث وما هي المخاوف
الاوروبيه تحديدا من هذا الانقلاب في
الجابون
يعني انا لا اخفي عليك يعني الصوره ليست
يعني دقيقه جدا حتى بالنسبه لباريس هناك
تردد ثم كنا رجاء تمديد متاخر في البدايه
على فقط على الناطق الرسمي للحكومه الذي
كان وزير للصحه السابقا لم يحدث اي
استنفار كما وقع في السابق ما بين
الخارجيه والرئاسه ومجلس الامن وانا اعتقد
ان ربما ان فرنسا على علمه وان هذا
الانقلاب في النهايه وانقلاب استباقي لمنع
حدث اخر ربما يضر بمصالح فرنسا اما
بالنسبه لاوروبا هناك تقليد يعني منذ
سنوات ان المستعمرات السابقه الفرنسيه هذه
الدول النفوذ دائما تترك المبادره لباريس
ان التصريح يكون اداره تكون باريس هي التي
تدير هذا الوضع وبعد ذلك تتدخل الدول
الاوروبيه لكن عموما القاعده العامه داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي هو الان نتدخل قبل فرنسا
ولا شاننا في ادانه في النهايه عمليه
تعتبر عمليه داخليه
السيد ادريس ايات ماذا بعد الان يعني الان
جرى الاعلان عن انه من يتولى المرحله
المقبله هو قائد الحرس الجمهوري وبالتالي
هل توافق على مقالته لنا السيده ليز لان
ما يحدث عمليا الان هو انقلاب داخل
العائله
نعم جزئيا نوافق ما ذهبت اليه انه هو
انقلاب داخل العائله لكن هذا الانقلاب
يعرف فقط بدايته لا يمكن لاحد ان يتنبه
حتى في المدى المتوسط باعتبار اننا شاهدنا
انقلابات مماثله في دول اولها كانت مالي
هنا كان
هنالك بعد التعارض بين والتباينات بين
التطلعات ومطالب الشعب وبين الرئيس
المرحله الانتقاليه الذي هو باندا اهينها
هذا الذي سيؤدي الى انقلاب ثاني وسياتي
بالرئيس اسيميت الذي قطع حبل الوصال كليا
مع فرنسا شيء مماثل حدث في بوركينا فاسو
ايضا بعد الانقلاب فجاء رجل يسمى دامبا
وارتكب النفس الخطا الذي اعتقده ارتكبه
برايس
الاول لصهيفه فرنسيه هي صحيفه فقام
الانقلاب عليه من الرئيس ابراهيم تراوري
فاعتقد انه
الكره بملعب الرئيس
المجلس الانتقالي حاليا الذي يعلن عنه
اما ان يتماشى امام مطالب الشعب والتي
بدات من 2017 بمظاهره عالمه لطرد الصفائح
القاعده الفرنسيه الموجوده في البلاد اما
يتماشى ما هو يتماشابيه او قد يحدث انقلاب
اخر في الانقلاب فلا اعتقد
ادريس بالنسبه تحديدا للمصالح الفرنسيه
تبدو اقرب الى
ما تسعى اليه فرنسا هل هي تحاول تلطيف
الموقف من اجل ضمان مصالحها في الغابون ام
انها كانت على علم مسبق ربما بما كان
سيجري وهي ضامنه مسبقا لمصالحها الان
[موسيقى]
انه من المبكر ان نتحدث عن هذه النقطه
بالنسبه الى الوضعيه الشامله في الجابو لا
اعتقد ان امورا متعدده سوف تتغير وما كانت
لتتغير اصلا مع الرئيس بونغو اذا بونجو
كان مقربا من القوى الغربيه ارى ان الصين
وهي الشريك الاكبر للجابون ننسى في بعض
الاحيان ان هناك
جهات اخرى متعدده معنيه الصين وهي الشريك
الاكبر
للجابون باضافه الى روسيا كذلك
والامين العام للامم المتحده دانه هذا
الانقلاب اذا هذا الانقلاب بنسبه الى
الجابون طبعا موجه ايضا باتجاه فرنسا هناك
موقف فرنسي صعب اذا بالنسبه الى الفرنسيين
هل لديهم دور لست متاكده لا اعرف اعتقد
انه في المرحله الراهنه هذه المسائل وهذه
الاسئله لا تزال مفتوحه على المستوى
الاقتصادي لا اعتقد ان امورا متعدده سوف
تتغير ولكن المؤكد هو ان كل هذه
الانقلابات التي تحصل في البلدان
الفرانكفونيه
تصعب
وضع بنسبه الى فرنسا ومنطقه النفوذ
الفرنسيه هذه هناك تغيرات تحصل في بلد تلو
الاخر وهذا مبعث قلق
بالنسبه الى فرنسا
بعد قليل دكتوره ليزلي فيما يحدث في
المنطقه ككل في غرب افريقيا ولكن في مساله
الجابون كيف ستقارب هذا الانقلاب السلطات
الفرنسيه بالنظر الى ما فعلت مع النيجر
مثلا
اظن للغايه من الصعوبه ان نعرف هل فرنسا
طبعا لانه ليس باستطاعتها ان تقول الليله
سوف اغادر او هناك حاجه الى تدخل عسكري
بالنسبه الى المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول وسط
افريقيا ايضا هناك دور يجب ان تؤديه
وبالتالي فرنسا لا يمكنها ان تقول سوف نشن
عمليه عسكريه في الغابون لاعاده علي بانجو
هذا واضح باستطاعه فرنسا ان تضغط
سياسيا ولكن ليس باستعطيها ان تتخذ خطوات
عمليه اذا هل سوف تتراجع فرنسا في مواقفها
التي كانت متشدده بالمقارنه مع النيجر على
سبيل المثال هذا هو السؤال هل سوف تخفف
النبره هذا هو السؤال الاساسي دكتور حس
عبادي كسر اليوم توقفوا عند جمله وردت على
لسان جوزيف بوريل عندما كان يعلق على هذا
الانقلاب في الجابون قال يجب على وزراء
الدفاع والخارجيه في اوروبا التفكير بعمق
اذاء ما يحدث في افريقيا وتحسين سياساتنا
تجاه هذه الدول كيف يمكن فهم الرساله من
وراء هذا الموقف
السياسات المتبعه من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
منذ سنوات يعني كل تقريبا كل رئاسه لنفوض
للسياسه الخارجيه ياتي تصريح مشابه بالقول
بانه لابد من اعاده التفكير في سياستنا
تجاه هذه الدول لكن دائما يكون هناك فيتو
يكون هناك تدخل من قبل الدول المباشره
لديها فعلا تدخل عسكري لا يمكن لالمانيا
التي ارسلت فقط مبررات لمنطقه الساحل ان
تتدخل عسكريا الان بدات بدات نوعا ما خاصه
بمساهمتها الماليه وبالتالي من الصعب في
النهايه قول الاتحاد الاوروبي بولندا
ايرلندا هناك دول اوروبيه غير مهتمه اصلا
بقضيه قضيه الدول الافريقيه وقضيه اعاده
حتى السياسه التي تقول هي اصلا ليست ليست
لديها سياسه افريقيه ما عدا بعض الدول
الجنوبيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي مثل ايطاليا
اسبانيا كذلك والبرتغال لديها علاقات
تاريخيه مع الدول الافريقيه الدول
ربما التي تشهد انقلابات
تصبح حليفه المعسكرات المناهضه لاوروبا
خصوصا في هذا التوقيت واوروبا تواجه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا
هذا موضوع ثاني يعني اوروبا بدات تتدخل او
بدات تبدي اهتماما في افريقيا فقط عندما
رات بان الصين قبل كل شيء الصين ضعفت
وضاعفت الحجم التجاري مع الدول الافريقيه
ثم كذلك عندما رات روسيا رغم ان روسيا
يعني ليس لديها مبادلات تجاريه مهمه ابدا
يعني اوروبا اكثر بكثير يعني بما حجم
المعاملات التجاريه بين روسيا والدول
الافريقيه لكن الخوف من النفوذ الروسي
خاصه بعد التوغل فاجنر هذا هو الذي يخيف
لكن في النهايه نبقى دائما في نفس المعضله
وهو المعيار الامني المقاربه الامنيه التي
تنتجها التي تنتجها الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي والتي تشبه كذلك المقاربه
الفرنسيه اذا فعلا تم التغيير هذه
المقاربه يمكن القول فعلا بان اوروبا يمكن
ان يمكن فعل السياسه الاوروبيه ان تتغير
وهل تترك فرنسا هذا الموضوع لكن الرئيس
ماكرون في خطابه منذ يومين قال بانه يجب
التغيير هذه السياسه قال لابد ان نغادر
الى غير ذلك هناك استعداد جاهزيه فرنسيه
حتى اصلا في تغيير سياستها لان اراد انها
فشلت في النهايه وانها النخب تغيرت النخب
القريبه لفرنسا تغيرت الان وبالتالي لابد
من ان يكون لكن لم تكن تنتظر بانه وتيره
التغيرات تصل الى هذا هذا المستوى التي لا
يمكن لاي دوله في النهايه ان تضاعي ادريس
ايه ما المتوقع على صعيد القاره والمؤسسات
القاريه الافريقيه من موقف تجاه ما يجري
في الغابون ونحن بانتظار اجتماع غدا
نعم الحقيقه انه المتوقع حاليا الان صار
متناول
الجميل وكل عين فاحشه تدرك انها لا يمكن
ان تتجاوز
التمديدات وكذلك الادانات لانه حاله
الغابون كما ذكرت لك استاذه هاله خاصه
اضافه الى انه حتى المنع المراكبين
القاريين من الدخول لمراقبه الانتخابات
ادى الى بعض الاستياء في الاوساط الاتحاد
الافريقي نفسه اضافه الى ان القوى
الاقليميه جميعها تعرف حالات مماثله فتخاف
ان تتحول العدوى اليها او ربما تبدا
شعوبها بالثوره فاعتقد ان المستوى
الاقليمي والمستوى القاري لن تتجاوز
الادانات وهناك حاله اخرى خاصه ايضا لا
يشير الجميع اليها وهو انه الرئيس الي
بونجو نفسه حتى من قبل اقرانه ونذراه
الرؤساء يرون انه رئيسا تجاوزت مصالحه
وليس في حاله صحيه جيده
عنه او توته تبريرا كما هو الحال مع
الرئيس محمد بازون في جمهوريه النيجر مثلا
فانما راينا استنجاده بالمجتمع الدولي
لايك ما كان قادرا ان يوفي عبارات مفيده
تستطيع ان تفهم على نطاق واسك انه رجل
دوله يتحدث او الحاله التي ابدا فيها كان
مزريا او كانه طفل يحتاج الى رعايه طبيه
او غيرها جميع هذه الانطباعات تركت انه
الغابون حاله الغابون هي حاله خاصه يمكن
ان يتجاوز ويحل بفتره انتقاليه قصيره
واعتقد ان الرئيس المرحله الانتقاليه
في هذا الاطار حيث كرر اكثر من مره انه لا
يحدد مصالح الحلفاء الاقليميين والدوليين
اضافه الى انه لا يريد ان يتشبث بالسلطه
يريدوا فتره انتقاليه وانقاذ البلاد ثم
اتاح الى سلطه مدنيه اخرى فاعتقد ان
الامور ستكون يسيره لدى الاتحاد الافريقي
والسلطات القاريه والاقليميه للتعامل معها
لتغابن لانه لا تب دي تشددا او محاوله
الابتعاد الغربيه التي لديها مصالح في
الدوله نعم هل نحن امام
دومينو انقلابات في افريقيا وبالتالي كيف
ستتعامل فرنسا مع ذلك لانه يعني اكثر
متضرر من ما يحدث هو النفوذ الفرنسي في
القاره
اذا طبعا هناك اتانه هذه الادانه كانت
متوقعه ولكنها اتت مخففه ولم نشهد اي موقف
اضافي دعينا نتجاوز هذه النقطه وننتقل الى
الدكتور حسني عبيدي دكتور حسني هذه
الانقلابات كذلك من وجهه نظر بعض
المسؤولين الغربيين تشكل انتكاسه لما
يعتبرونهم مكاسب ديمقراطيه حدثت في هذه
الدول لان بالنهايه من يقوم بها هم العسكر
ويعني يحلون
قوى عسكريه في السلطه الى اي مدى هذا يعكس
حقيقه ما يجري والواقع عمليا بالنظر الى
الحاله في الغابون وغيرها
مفارقه وان المؤسسه العسكريه او الجيش هو
الذي يقوم بالعمليه ودائما يجد ذريعه
احيانا محق وحين غير محق وهو اعاده
الديمقراطيه واعاده المؤسسات اي ان الحكم
المدني جزء كبير من الحكم المدني في
النهايه الحفاظ على هذه المؤسسات او تمادى
في السلطه ولم يستطيع ينظم في النهايه هذه
التعدديه التي تعيق او تمنع دخول العسكري
بممارسه السياسه هذا النقطه والنقطه
الثانيه هي هذه الدول الغربيه اصلا لديها
مسؤوليه كبيره يعني لم تساعد هذه الحكومات
الانتقاليه التي هي هشه اقتصاديا وهش
سياسيين باعتبار ان المؤسسه العسكري الجيش
هم المؤسس الاكثر استقراضا اكثر قوه التي
لديها قوه كبيره عسكريه وماديه وبالتالي
من الصعب جدا على احزاب سياسيه هزيله وحتى
السلطه مدنيه في النهايه ان تقاوم رغبه
العسكر العوده الى استلام السلطه في اي
لحظه من اللحظات طيب دكتور حسني باختصار
شديد الان
بعد كل ما حدث نتحدث عن ثمانيه انقلابات
منذ عشرين عشرين في غرب افريقيا اليوم ما
جرى ما تاثيره على الاوضاع في القاره لا
سيما في غربا باختصار
هناك تاثير كبير يعني هناك خوف الان على
السنغال هناك خوف على
وهناك على الاقل اقل خوف ما يحدث في
النيجر باعتبارنا الحده ستخف اذا استطاع
في النهايه العسكر في بانجو اداره هذه
المرحله لكن فعلا الان اصبح الحكم المدني
في مازق شكرا جزيلا لك من جنيف الدكتور
حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه
جنيف وشكرا لضيفنا من الكويت ادريس ايه
الاكاديمي النيجيري والخبير بشؤون
الافريقيه والدكتوره ليزلي فارين مديره
معهد دراسات العلاقات الدوليه
والاستراتيجيه في باريس
نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]